This is a weird, but true.
A scandal has rocked the world of award-winning
nature photography.
You wouldn't think there'd be a scandal
in the world of nature photography.
True story.
There is a Brazilian photographer named Marcio Cabral.
Took this stunning photo of an anteater
approaching a glowing termite mound at night.
This is a photo that he took.
Isn't that gorgeous?
You see the anteater moving in.
Well, guess what?
The photo's been hanging in a British museum
because people revere it.
Until they just discovered Cabral had used
a stuffed anteater to take the photo.
Yes!
And this is a huge scandal in the world of photography.
Now they're starting to question the authenticity
of other famous photos Cabral has taken.
There's this photo of a wild mustang standing proudly
in the wilderness.
People are worried about it.
(audience laughter)
Yeah, there is
worry about that one, yeah.
There's this photo of a timber wolf swimming
across a swollen stream.
Look at that wolf go!
(audience laughter)
There's this dramatic photo of a shark
attacking a boat.
Something didn't seem right!
(audience laughter)
There's this flock of flamingos walking in the snow.
(audience cheer)
Yeah.
And finally, this photo of a group of aggressive
Galapagos tortoises fighting over some food.
People are worried about it.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(laughs)